hello
everyone my name is michael yan and i'm
the
ceo and founder of a company called
second state
we do software performance engineering
welcome to my talk
this is my home office in austin texas
during the pandemic
and um i hope you enjoyed this talk and
i hope we can meet in person soon
let me start sharing my screen first
let me move myself to the corner okay
pretend
okay so here we go well um the
the topic of this talk is performance
engineering
for application developers especially
web application developers
so when this topic came up um a lot of
people
ask why you know because um for for many
years
the the main challenge of web
application is not performance
that is very evident with the rise of
frameworks like
first with java and with ruby on rails
and with
no javascript on node.js you know those
all those frameworks are not known for
their performance
they are known for their productivity
developer productivity use of use
and all those other features safety and
all those other features just not
performance
right and uh over time they get
optimized a lot but
when they first came out um
most people would say those are slow
languages when java first came out it's
definitely a slow language it has a
reputation for that right
ruby first came out the job when
javascript was first used on the server
it's the same reaction and people
typically have two answers to that
the first answer is what we call the
biogas answer is to say
um yes i know it's kind of slow but
um technology evolved so fast so in
three four months
you know it'd be fast enough oh well
that's
actually the answer bill gates gave when
people criticize
that the windows software is too bloated
he basically said
um the cpu of the computer is evolving
so fast
so what's slow today it's not going to
be slow tomorrow so why spend all this
time
you know optimizing things that are
going to improve on itself
right why wouldn't you spend time that's
optimized for user experience and
features and other things that are that
kind of have long-term value
which i thought it worked really well
for them for him
and for microsoft right you know the
second argument is
oh you know i'm just writing a web
application you know that's the
application all the application does is
babysitting a database
you know someone come here request i go
to the database and fetch the answer
back to them
you know that's that use case it doesn't
need
a whole lot of performance so to speak
right you know so that's
that'll be the second answer you know i
don't need it the first answer is going
to improve by itself the first
the second answer is i don't need it but
i think things has changed in the past
couple years
that's forced us you know for us for the
entire industry to have an entirely
different look at this whole problem
so i referred to an article that
published on the journal science
only a couple months ago the spot those
are top computer scientists
published this article and uh from the
title of this article you can get a hand
you know there's plenty of room at the
top the top in
the top of the stack right because 40
years ago intel's golden motor wrote
article called there's plenty of room at
the bottom
the bottom of the stack is what is the
hardware the cpu
what he meant what dr mo meant is the
cpu
and hardware gonna continue improve at
the rapid pace
so everything else is gonna lift with
the time right you know so you don't
need to spend a lot of time optimizing
software
you can spend a lot of time optimizing
software in terms of
its developer product your human
productivity not the computer
connectivity
because what's slow today can be fast
enough three months from now
so that's what we refer to as more slow
apps that's basically driven the
productivity
improvement in the entire computer
industry for the
for the past 40 years so that's
essentially the first argument i just
gave right you know is that
yes it is so but it can improve
however this article talks about the
moore's law has
really has stopped as we all know you
know the computers and hardware are not
really getting faster
you know the clock speed is definitely
not getting faster it's uh
um the the the size of the transistor
has you know has gone down from say
you know 10 you know has gone down
little but not a lot right you know so
the
the way to get it faster is to do like
gpu or add more cores
to do more parallel computing and you
know things of that nature it's not
the raw performance is improving it's uh
you get you
you throw more compute using more
computers have the same problem
right so you know so that's perhaps
that's one of the biggest
challenges that's uh that the developers
today are going to face
that's either not did not really exist
in the past
40 years that's a completely new problem
that people can have and then there'll
be the second problem
is to say okay yeah it's
maybe not getting any faster but you
know all i do is database you know
that's
primarily limited by the network
bandwidth and hardware and the hard disk
speed
you know that's uh um you know and if
there's more requests i can just open
more servers you know there has been a
lot of study in terms of
work horizontal scalability of those
services so we can do charting and we
can do a lot of things so you know
that's
so why performance is so important well
that is because
um another thing happened in the past
five years when moral stopped
is on the software side we have figured
out
how to utilize more and more computing
power especially with
the emergence of say artificial
intelligence deep learning
and all those applications require a
huge amount of computing power
that is previously not available and
in order to incorporate those features
into
your application or into a web
application that you are building
that is not just database you would
actually
need to care about performance you know
um
as we'll see later in this talk there's
a huge difference in terms of
the software stock you choose versus the
performance you're gonna get
so here is the um the
the um figure one this in the science
paper right you know so how do you
how do we so hardware has stopped
improving
but the demand for computing power has
gone up what's the solution so the
leading computer scientists give us the
answer
you know they said there's plenty room
at the top meaning today's software
stack has
a lot of inefficiencies that we can
squeeze out by
doing software performance engineering
like i said that's what my company does
right you know that's why i'm giving
this talk
so it's removing the software bloat and
tailoring software to hardware you know
we have new hardware that's
designed for specific problems like for
deep learning and for you know
things like that or even for for you
know for
for bitcoin and for blockchain you know
there's special hardware being developed
for that
and to tailor software for that not just
to have generic software that designed
for cpu to access those hardware
so by combining those if you read this
paper you know the paper showed
you know a python program by rewriting
it in state of arts
c-class plus and running a custom hard
hardware
you can get a performance gain of four
orders of magnitude
that's over ten thousand times
performance
improvement so that's actually also is
something that
we have seen routinely by um you know
when people
have a web application that that does
database stuff
they don't do ai because not because
they don't want to but because
they can't you know because the software
stack is not efficient enough to support
this type of computing
applications and by changing the
software stack
we will be able to squeeze a lot more
performance without
changing the underlying hot cpu we may
need customizes
sorry
we may need to customize the software we
may need customized
hardware to be in the mix but not more
cp more cpu part because cpu part is not
improving anymore
so let's see a case study or example in
action okay
so the the goal here is to create a
cloud application
that runs tensorflow inference on an
image that's uh
you know i think that's
the use case a lot of people have
considered right you know that's i have
a
web service or web application that
would take an image and
then wrong tensorflow model there's
literally hundreds thousands of
tensorflow models trained for different
purposes
on those images on this image to do
things like facial recognition
or object classification you know
anything you can think of
you know so this is a typical use case
wrong tensorflow influence on the image
so depending on the software stack that
we use so if we
implement this tensorflow inference
metrics on say javascript and
and even run this javascript you know
very efficient
runtime so for instance in the web
assembly runtime in v8
in the interpreted mode you know meaning
the javascript running as the way it's
supposed to
you know as well it's designed you know
as a scripting language
we are looking at 10 minutes of time on
a state of
state of art cpu to process a single
image okay 10 minutes
that's clearly too long for web
application you know it's made okay it
may be okay
for say uh asynchronous functional
service that you need to
you know it's asynchronous so there's
plenty of time on the back end to
process those things
but 10 minutes for waiting is clearly
not good enough for web applications
so now we rewrite it in tensorflow.js in
just in time back or something you know
so that's a different that's
not in the interpreter mode but
tensorflow.js
is tensorflow's c library cross-compiled
into javascript or web assembly
through uh through the emcc compiler and
uh
it runs in the v8 web assembly using
with the just-in-time compiler
optimization
that's speed up significantly because
that allows the application to be
compiled and run instead of being
being just being interpreted that's
creates
that alarm creates 500 times performance
gain you know
it's reduced from 10 minutes to around
two seconds
you know two seconds i think it's pretty
it it's very acceptable for web
application now right you know that's uh
because
the the time you need to um
to do the network transmission and all
that is in order of seconds
so two seconds is probably good enough
for the single interaction like this
however if we optimize our web assembly
stack
it's not even go to native but go but do
web assembly with ahead of time
optimization for instance you know the
ss vm called second state vm is the web
assembly open source web assembly
implementation that we have
to to run the same application you can
get to
half a second which is full time
performance improvement again
you know that's half a second i think is
is very acceptable to to um you know to
most
i would say interactive web applications
right
but you can you can optimize it even
further
by giving it custom hardware like gpu
and then have the um have the compiler
optimized for
customized instructions for gpu you can
get another 10
times performance scan so it now goes to
0.05 seconds or less per image
if you think about that that pretty much
allows you to
process real-time video data because
real-time video data is about
30 frames per second right if you want
to recognize
every single face on every frame of a
video image of a video stream
you can more or less use this now you
know that's uh you know you
can do 30 seconds per 30 frames per
second
may not but you certainly have the
capability to do you know that's
um but you can sample it to do
like um once per
you know once you know do one
run recognition for every three frames
you know something like that right you
know so
to do that that's that type of
performance allow us
to actually do streaming video and the
wrong ai application on top of it
then of course you can have full native
meaning that you don't use webassembly
at all that you just write the
code in cc plus plus and then run
bare metal gpus and that would cause it
to be even less than even more
performance
you know that would be under 0.05
seconds
that's um so that's the range of things
that we can see
you know so we can see from you know
from javascript
being interpreted javascript so what is
two
um pre-compiled web assembly that is
basically in the same
family of technologies because web
assembly evolves from javascript right
you know same family of technologies and
we already got
four orders of magnitude improvement in
performance so
that means that i agree with the sign
saucers
there's plenty of room at the top and in
this talk
i want to give you some you know real
examples and tips
in terms of how to optimize for your own
application
all right so
that's the thing you know it's uh
there's a saying to say there's
it's turtles all the way down the world
is what is the world being built up
you know as we as we have looked at
we have just mentioned you know things
like javascript on ogs when the first
came out people say the performance is
not good enough you know that's
um you guys really need to improve
performance so far that's simple
performance
and now most people who use node.js
would think it performs pretty well you
know that's uh
that is because node.js fundamentally is
not a javascript framework it is a
javascript runtime
that's built on a c plus plus engine so
the google v8 is completely written in c
plus plus
and most of the common tasks you use in
node.js like the file system operation
like image resizing and you know those
those computing types of tasks they are
all written in native modules in c
class plus it's just providing a
javascript as the interface for
developers
so what we would argue is not just
to achieve the high performance today
not because it's a javascript
performance
platform runtime it's despite its use of
javascript
it's most of the heavy lifting spawned
by a native code
native machine code in c and c plus plus
the same thing happens in python you
know if you do um
heavyweight machine learning and the ai
applications you often use python to
write your
your application but you are only
writing using python as an interface
so all your python codes actually get
translated into native modules
they run natively in opencv and in
tensorflow all those libraries and
modules are written in c
plus plus and compiled machine code
so the trend has become very clear here
you know is that
we need something for developer
productivity you know javascript node.js
python
but on the other side of the things we
need something that is high performance
which is translate everything into
native binary code
and for most applications that
application developer develop
they set in the middle you know so if
you write a complex
node.js application a lot of your logic
can be executed in javascript
and some of them you know like um you
know image resizing or file operating
something
like like the things i just mentioned
would
have gained from the high performance of
the native modules but the more
application logic you have in your in
your application
the more business logic you have in your
application the more javascript you're
going to use
and the more javascript you can use it's
slower it goes
so for most application developers it's
a balance between those two right you
know that's
for very simple applications i can
achieve really high performance because
most of
because mostly all i do is to call the
native to call the apis you know js that
get translated into native
native function calls but as my
application grow more complex
as i'm an enterprise developer you know
if 80 percent of my logic
is actually building javascript that's
no corresponding negative library
then you can expect the application to
run pretty slow so that's
i think that's one of the challenges
that um you know more and more
developers are
finding out you know is to say not just
or python it's um it's it's really
performance if you follow the tutorials
but if you write a ton of your own code
then performance engineering become a
really big problem right you know so
that's a problem that's
we think well you know at least i think
would be more of a more
problem for for future developers
so because of all that you know that's
um we have seen
you know the moore's law is not it's not
holding and the demand
for performance is great and uh by
having choosing different frameworks you
can achieve vastly different performance
results
and most frameworks today actually go
with the route
of having a high level interface and
then
how to do the actual computing as native
code right
so that's how we define great
performance is to follow the lead
of what node.js and what python has done
in the past
on the performance side we only have one
requirement
is it should be as fast as a native
library you know so
it's so if we come up with a new
framework in node.js
that does high performance we say high
performance computing
it should make the javascript
application you write
as fast as fast as the native library of
the
of the node.js api calls right you know
so that's
so on the speed side that's the only
requirement that we have
however on the other side
which is a software engineering side
there's lots of other requirements
that the framework must must be able to
satisfy in order for developers to use
it
because in the end i can you you know if
if speed is all that matters then i can
write everything in c class plus and
people are not doing it and people will
not do it
because there's the native binary have
all kind of problems
we need other things that's other
benefits of software engineering that
has happened in the past
say 25 or 30 years since java came along
right
you know the the safety and the security
of the runtime
the portability of the software so that
i can compile it on my mac
and then run on linux right i don't have
i don't need to have the exact same
machine
on my development environment and on the
deployment environment
and i can move it around in different
deployment environments i can manage it
i can allocate resources to it and
i can tell you know i i
i can say which resources should i have
access to and which is not i can stop it
i can restart it
i can move it to another machine you
know all kinds of
other things like he the the ik folks
would want
the new framework would need to be able
to integrate with existing ecosystems
you can't have something that is brand
new because
you know the learning curve of something
like that could be really sharp and it
takes 10 years for say ruby on rails to
get popular right and also
for node.js so you know so so something
to get a developer mine chair you also
need to have it to integrate with a
large existing ecosystem
and it needs to have high developer
productivity we are
looking to squeeze performance from the
top but it's not in the way that it's
crude
that is only optimized for the machine
and we also want
to make it so that we preserve the
software engineering
gains that we achieved through the past
30 or 40 years right
you know so that we want the the way we
do it is to native performance
but with all those nice features that
manage languages or manage long runtimes
that gave us
so is there that sounds like a wish list
right you know and
i think um node.js and python have
achieved some balance of it that's
precisely why they're successful
but i also but i also mentioned their
shortcoming is that if you write that's
um they
they provide api for that but they don't
have a way
for for they don't have the flexibility
for developers to write
say arbitrary javascript or python
applications and achieve the same
performance as our native api provides
so what's our answer
well so the first thing we need to
really think about is
choosing a battle of programming
languages right you know so if you we
want to write high performance
application
like the the science paper also on
bluetooth the software blocks start with
our choice of programming languages
i i frequently refer to cc plus plus
that's the most efficient but not for
everyone
because of all this the safety and the
portability and other things that we
described
and here is a table of the performance
of different languages
and the you know in terms of execution
time and
the memory it takes for the wrong time
and you see
you know some languages like python
it's very very slow and java takes a
huge amount of memory at the wrong time
c c plus plus is probably
would be can be used as a benchmark you
know they are they are small and
efficient
and what's the second comp it's rust
right rust is a very popular programming
language
it's uh well it's um
it's popular as a cc plus plus
replacement because it provides a lot of
the high level programming language
features to see cnc plus plus it make it
far more productive to write safe code
and secure coding rust designing c-class
plus
and because of that um it is a
fast-growing programming language and
it's also one of um it's
i think five years in a row it's it's
the most beloved programming language
by um you know the stack overflow survey
so i think russ would be a pretty good
language
to choose to to to write high
performance applications that can run
inside
environments like node.js you agree so
that's um
that's my assessment and if you don't
agree that's um
you know email me or you know get in
touch because this
um talking about which programming
language is better is a holy war right
you know is that
everybody has their own opinion it's
just my opinion i i like rust that's why
i'm giving a talk here
right so
however how do we run rust code on the
web you know so there's
there's old way you know it's i think
that's the predominant way that people
do it now
is to do um is to write it as an as a
native module you know so i
create a web web server that is
has a native module right you know this
could be node.js it could be apache it
could be a lot of things
and it's just right or have
a web server that's written in rust so
that it can execute
roster application logic behind the http
interface right you know so
there are a lot of projects done this
way and
they have seen a lot of a huge
performance gain over
other approaches like node.js within
javascript right
um however the problem with that is the
problem we have mentioned
it has to run for native code it's not
friendly to the cloud providers
it's not even friendly to the i.t
department because
people cannot really audit the native
code and even if you are completely
trustworthy yourself you say
my code has no bugs and uh
and has no security problem whatsoever
but most of those code depend on certain
particle libraries and those libraries
might have problems
so running native code is always
a issue for big organizations so that's
um
in my opinion that's what handles the
the adoption of rust in big enterprise
at this moment right because
the need to run things in native and
even with containers it's not completely
safe and it has
you know it has all kinds of issues
which we can talk about in
a minute so a better way is really to
compare to
manage the bytecode the the approach
that java has pioneered 20 years ago
right you know so
to compile it into a byte code and run
inside the managed vm
give it a lot of benefits and this vm
today is the leading choice of this vm
is web assembly
so here's the co-founder of docker he
said this last year you know
whoever somebody on the server is the
future of computing he even turned out
to say
that if web assembly and the web
assembly system interface has existed
in 2008 they would not have invented
docker right you know that is how
important it is it's a
it's a new high-level container that
allows us
to run bytecode that compiled from a
highly efficient programming language
so that's something that we have not
seen in
a long time in computing in in this
industry
so i think that's what most exciting
about it
so the benefit of the web assembly vm i
think we have touched those points
many of those points early on in my
slides so the first of course is
security because provide a sandbox it
protects from yourself
and protects from all the dependencies
your application has
so that you don't have to run them at
native and it also provides something
called capability-based security
it's it's a part of the manageability
manageability issue it allows you when
you start up the vm
you can specify which um file system
directory it has access to which
environmental variables it has access to
so it's you can have an independent
security policy that independ
that independent from the operating
system itself right so security is a big
draw for
running rust compiled high efficiency
code
in in web assembly vm
so but of course all this is not
human issue if it's not fast right you
know so wherever somebody
has to meet the because we are talking
about high performance computing
it has to meet the requirements that is
can run at close to negative speed
you know so bytecode running web
assembly should be
almost as fast as bytecode compiled to
the machine binary
as we will see in a minute that is
actually true which
is maybe surprising to a lot of people
of course one time safety is related to
um security
is to say when application crashes it
should not affect
other applications that's running in the
same system you know docker give you
some of that but we're going to talk
about
the problem with docker you know minix
is mostly related to performance
and the possibility platform
independence is also a big draw
is that i can write my application on a
developer machine
and i i can run windows or mac or
whatever
and then the same application can be
executed
in a cloud provider i don't even need to
know what's operating system the cloud
provider
is using and what standard libraries it
has
so its platform independence is a big
draw and the manageability we
we just talked about that it can be
moved around it can
you can allocate resource to it and
you know those nice features that the vm
can give you
okay so here's a graph that's a study
that we did
um for where are some web assemblies
especially um you know we we use the
second state vm
as an example versus stalker
so those are execution times so the
shorter the bar the better
right you know the shorter the bar
meaning the the smaller amount of time
it takes to accomplish the task
um at the bottom two benchmarks nop and
cad sync
are startup times and file system
performance
one thing that really stands out is that
um node.js isn't that bad
you know when compared with docker
native and docker node.js
running the same application node.js is
only about 100
times slower than than than the native
application
you know that's um that is of course
because you know all those standard
benchmarks
are actually being optimized in objects
so if you just want to do
a new number crunch you know because
those are essentially one number crunch
you know that's um you are calculating
the binary tree you know three body
problems you know things
and body problems and you know things
like that and those are number quenching
and
those things are very heavily optimized
in the
node.js um v8 runtime
so
when the javascript runtime engine sees
something like that
it actually knows how to build a very
efficient
machine native code to actually execute
those so that's
why it's i would say
you know in a in a you know realistic
benchmarks the node.js is going to be
10 times or maybe even 100 times slower
than the native code if you
run everything interpret javascript mode
but for because the benchmark is
structured
it's actually not that bad it's a sonic
price as well so but what's really
really surprising
is in almost all cases the web assembly
runtime
meaning the byte code the rust code
compiled to bytecode and then wrong
inside the safe sandbox vm
is actually faster than it's running in
darker
plus native code so
i think many people challenge this
result you know we we have shown this
result to
two different people you know that's um
we're going to talk about that in a
minute
and people challenge this result to say
how is that possible that is that
doesn't sound possible because the
machine code
even with star card because docker has
very minimal overhead
the machine code should definitely be
faster than running inside the sandbox
that is because the way the
the virtual machine technology has
evolved over the past
i would say 20 years pioneered by java
is
the aot compilation you know the ahead
of time combination
so when when the vm sees this
um web assembly bytecode the first thing
does is to compile it to machine code
and then run it so in the process of
compiling to machine code it can have
many
different optimization options that is
not available
when you compile it to docker plus
native
when you compile a roster c plus plus
application to full native application
you actually get um
you specify a set of you know compiler
optimization flags
that's depend on that is fairly generic
that
depends on your guess of solving of the
target system so for instance
you're going to say it's an intel
processor it has
you know it has well yeah so
it's a x86 processor and uh com
and optimize for that right but for ssvm
and web assembly
knows exactly the type of machine it's
running up
it knows it's an intel processor or amd
processor
it knows how much memory it has so it
can intelligently choose the compilation
facts that make you
run faster you know because all this is
done
dynamic at the wrong time not at the
compile time anymore the compile time
you just generate the intermediate byte
port right
so that allows the web assembly to have
even higher performance than native code
so you know that's one of our
requirements is that
as fast as native uh machine code right
but you can see
from those benchmarks the web assembly
bytecode
with iot compilation is actually better
you know in terms of compile that's
a very surprising result and because
because of this this results that we um
that we wrote an article that is peer
reviewed that is
already accepted for publication in ieee
software it's going to come out
this year you know it's called the
library design for serverless function
as a service it compares
um the second state vm against uh
leading serverless containers including
docker i'm not fire from amazon
firecracker and the google's g by the
plus stalker
you know um so this is a research favor
that's
that's already peer reviewed and
accepted and if you um
if you want to uh a preprint of it let
me know
and i'll send you one so that's um
but that's the surprise result is that
web assembly provides safety
and better performance you know you
don't have to compromise between safety
developer productivity against the
native code performance you know
you can actually do both you know so
that's that's a big takeaway from this
paper
and maybe from this talk as well so
let's click this
so
so let's
look at the application architecture
that's
that's a typical
web as a rust web assembly-based
application run inside node.js
so on the front end there will be the
node.js javascript runtime and so
developers can write things
in javascript as they they want to
because that's that's proven again again
developers want to write their
application you know most of their
application in javascript
and when it comes in the runtime figures
out
the what the application is actually
doing
is actually the application is making
native function is making node.js
function costs
it's typically dedicated to the c plus
plus based
module library so that it can go on and
uh
gets of the and
executed as native binary but as we said
the native binary is all nice if it's
audited and if it's safe
but a lot of them are not unless it's
come pre-packaged original js to install
third-party native libraries
it's always a challenge so for the other
computational intensive tasks
it could optimize it could optionally
route it into a web assembly runtime
and run an inside web assembly and get
the result returned back to
javascript so for instance this could be
a whole it could be a complete task of
image recognition or facial recognition
so where about some
the node.js runtime just pass the image
into the model
to the web assembly runtime and it would
do file system access
you know access the gpu and do all that
stuff do all that magic
then and this particular web assembly
code web assembly
virtual machine code is compiled from a
rust program
so for developers they write two pieces
of software
one is the javascript
application that handles the web related
stuff
and then the javascript can calls apis
part of the api
is the rust application the developer
has written and the compiled web
assembly
so we're going to show a very concrete
example in a minute so let's just um you
know
and there's also a link if you are
interested you can go to that website
and see you know that's how exactly
different components of this system can
work together
all right so now
let's look at the demo you know that's
ai as a service
um go to this
website second state dot io slash fast
what is fast it's not fast it's fast you
know it's a function
as a service it's web assembly based
function of the service
so let me switch my screen share to
to this website
okay
all right so here we go so that's
the web page it's our you know it says
demo spotlight and stroll all the way
down it has a lot of tutorials and the
code which
we're going to see at the example in
minutes so let's go to do
face recognition it's it goes to an
application that we wrote to say detect
faces
and this application i think it's
represents a future meaning that's
it is a completely static application
there's no server here
it's just you can put it anywhere in
github pages or any static or even
hosted locally
and what it does it's it's
make a request to a serverless function
that deplo
the service functions written in web
assembly reading rust and compiled web
assembly
and the serverless function with the
processor requesting ajax and come back
to this webpage
so this so all you need is a service
where you can deploy your website
web assembly function and pay for each
location
there's no need to stand up a server
that's 24 7
process report to process image upload
and all that stuff
so let's do how it works you know so you
choose a file you choose an image
and of course you can do a lot more and
then you say find faces
what it does is that takes the image
it's um
it's it makes the web services called it
goes to the
goes to the fast the function of the
service the functional service
executes the the web assembly function
and the markup first detect all the
image
all the faces on that image and then
draw those green boxes around each face
and then generates the return image and
the return image back
to our browser so that we can see the
result so this fully interactive
application you don't
it's available 24 7 but you don't need
to start a server and pay for the server
to make it available
right so you can come here and use that
at any time and we are
you know as um you know
as a whole sort of of the service i'm
not paying anything
i'm only paying for each request right
you know so for all the times i don't
it's um it does not generate anything
for me
so um some of you might recognize you
know this is a nobel prize season and
this is a
1927 subway conference it's probably the
most
famous uh conference in the history of
science and there's 29 phases here
you may recognize some you know most
people would recognize albert einstein
in here
but 19 of those people 19 of the 29
people
later get got nobel prize and some of
them got twice like
you know madame cleary she got it twice
right you know so so this is uh perhaps
uh the
the greatest mind in modern history and
you know that's we submit the image
and the computer wrong tensorflow model
and detect all the faces and then came
back
very simple and uh and spent most of the
time
uploading image and getting it back and
rendered in the browser
right you know that's um the the actual
time to do image recognition on the
server is under one second
it's you know it's come 100 milliseconds
at this point and we can
we also we can optimize a lot more you
know but i just want to show you this
example
and then let's see another example image
classification for instance that's also
another very popular tensorflow model
that i choose an image and i say
i already know it's a dark so i want to
classify it you know to see um it runs a
tensorflow model
to say it runs the tensorflow
model to to try to detect what is
on that image and then give the
confidence of that right
you know so in this case it doesn't
return an image back it's return a json
string
so it's um it looks up it's
um it's it's it's object classification
table and said it's a part which is
which it is and this uh it knows that
has a very high confidence right you
know so this whole process
take again on the server it takes
several milliseconds
and most of the time it takes it
actually goes to
you know gets the image and and that's
you know
submit to the server and then come back
and all this time
um i don't need to pay anything you know
as a as a
as a service provider i don't need to
pay anything because i have no server
you know i just have a bunch of html
and then i have a function of the
service sitting somewhere and
someone hits it i'll pay a fraction to
it
but i don't pay for all the idle times
so that's high performance computing
plus
the new building model that gives us a
lot of flexibility right
so let's go back to our site
all right here we go
so we have just seen a example of air as
a service i
are welcome you to go to that website
and play it with yourself and then
see all the source code it's all on
github you know that you can see all of
them and
and and then see how you know but we all
walk through one of the
one of the source coding in the
remainder of this clock so that you know
how it works
this is the demo and the architecture of
this thing
is um what i've just described the
overall architecture but
let me dive a little deeper into it to
see how it works
so on the node.js is a javascript app
for
the web network and the database tasks
that's um that's handled by functional
service
so that's out of the question here
so what we start is the roster source
code it's a function itself
the function gets the input from the
from the surface which is the image that
the user uploaded
and it does all the heavy lifting of the
image processing you know resize it to
the right
amount to the right size select the
tensorflow model
and pass the image and tensorflow model
to tensorflow and then
get after result come back it does the
things like drawing the
boxes around faces and then generates
the json and
makes sense what the what the result is
and then
gets the result back so it's a heavy
lifting is all done in the rust
source code and it's compiled into ever
somewhere and executed in web assembly
and then the actual tensorflow work is
actually done through an interface
called
what we call a tensorflow oc or the aic
system interface
so because this is a fairly standard
system command that requires the full
native functionality you know it's not
um it doesn't really make sense to run
inside web assembly because it's so
standard
right you know that's um you know
there's very little chance that anyone
would be able to make it unsafe
or you know that's uh so so so all the
benefit of webassembly is not here
but to make a standard interface in the
rust api so that developer can cause
tensorflow has tremendous value for
developer productivity right
so we have a native uh a native wrapper
of the tensorflow command
that can be invoked from web assembly so
whenever somebody
runs on the runs inside the
function of the service that it's a
process or the application logic
and when says when it encounters the
task that needs to
tensorflow it pass off to the native
command network command executes that
and it returns back
into web web assembly process all this
at the end and then return back to
node.js and
then give it back to us so that's the
whole process
of the of the application
so the node node.js code again it's very
simple it's just to take the image and
return it
and what's important is the rust and web
assembly code
and as we see this is the
meat of the application this is why you
need to write application logic you have
a
new rust and web assembly because each
of this stuff can be very slow
if you just write them in in javascript
and so the first is you load the image
that the user has gave you
has uploaded and you resize it to the
model the tensorflow demands right you
know so for image recognition
tensorflow demands 224 by 224 image size
with rpg values for each pixel
so you so you resize whatever the format
you get an image from the jpg jpeg or
png or whatever
you normalize in the format format into
that particular format the tensorflow
can
accept and then you load the model data
you select which tensorflow model you
want to run against this mod
this this particular um
this particular image right is that face
detection or is that
um is surface recognition or is that
object detection
so you choose the model data and choose
the
data that associated with the models for
instance in this particular example is
image
is object classification but all
tensorflow give back
numbers and you have to map number into
the actual words for the object like a
dark or caps or you know uniform or
whatever
so that's um so you need a label file
and we reap the label file that goes
with the model here as well
then step number four is to actually
execute the tensorflow model
which we're going to talk about in the
next slide and once we execute the
tensorflow model it gives back
a bunch of numbers it gives back array
of tensors right you know so
that's what tensor is you know that's a
fun fact you know that's
um the tensor was popularized by albert
einstein
which we saw in last picture because he
needs that for general relativity
you know so now we are using tensorflow
to recognize a picture of our
lines then so that's well
anyway just something i i thought it'd
be interesting to mention
so in in number five we have the command
return value
as as floating numbers and then we look
up the table
to map those numbers and probabilities
into the objects or the images that
have if we do face recognition we would
load the image again and
draw those circles using rust and web
assembly to do it in a way that is high
performance much high performance than
any javascript library can ever achieve
and then send the result back to us so
that is
what we call you know um in our in our
way of doing that what we call high
performance function
you know it's a function of written in
rust and the compiled web assembly so
that it can ride four negative speed
and it's have access to the operating
system or to other system resources that
can
can make it around even faster right you
know that's for instance in terms of
flow we don't have to rewrite tensorflow
and rust
we just make a system call from the web
assembly runtime that shows
the um you know how flexible the purpose
on the runtime is
online and it integrates with javascript
on the other end
it integrates with the native operating
system
so number four we you know step number
four we left out is what we call was it
for tensorflow what is
you know web assembly system interface
it's
commonly defined as how to use web
assembly to access system resources
like the file system the sockets random
number generator the clock and you know
things like that
but we can use washi to access any
command
that's available on the system in this
case we have the system installed
um tensorflow command so we use washi to
access this command
by having webassembly security we can
actually at the time of
um you know when we initialize the
website runtime we can say which command
you have access to
so that it has no unpredictable behavior
maybe this
this particular um maybe this um maybe
this particular instance can only have a
particular kind of tensorflow model
and uh and others that we can
we can specify this or when we start out
the
developer somebody wrong time so that's
why we say web assembly is more secure
and more manageable than native
applications right here's
example right here so to execute this
tensorflow model where command
we specify which model which family of
model it is we just
selected a model file right but we also
need to tell it what's the structure of
the model and so there's different
commands for that
and we're in this particular case it's
mobilenet
version two and then we give it
arguments so the input r so the
the tensor name in this model for the
input argument is called
input and the argument for the output is
soft max
um and the size of the image that's the
model expect
is 225 224 by 224
and after that we loads them we load the
the model data and the image data into
the command so that the command
runs the model against the image so the
actual
execution of this command is actually
online it's command.output it's called
the command it's called the command
swazi
and then the results come back and
we package the result into a json string
and then
we have then the the the rust and
whereby something
application continues to process this
and return this value
so that's the whole application you know
that's the application is just
a single function that's written in rust
and does most of the work um
in the compile webassembly but when it
does needs
um the um you know the help from the
operating system or from system install
command like tensorflow
it calls out so a well-defined
and can be um a well-defined interface
that can be secured
so that's that's our application
you know so as you can see you know
that's
um one of the work that we do is that we
try to make
as many types of tensorflow models
available you know in our ecosystem
right you know so
um this is all open source so there's
many family of tensorflow
models that we can incorporate into as a
rust apis right you know we just have
shown you there's a
mobile net rust api that calls
the mobilenet family of
tensorflow models and each and the
mobilenet family of tensorflow models
has
you know i think hundreds not solving
the models that people train
you know to recognize different things
you know you have about
various models that are very
specifically to recognize
different types of docs or you have a
model that they recognize
different objects on your on your on
your desk you know something like that
right you know so there's a lot of ways
that you can have different models
and so we would like to have a um
to have an open source project like the
tensorflow model loop but it's
tensorflow model
lou forever somebody right you know so
to have those models being pre-packaged
and made available through open source
projects so that anyone
in that using rust and whether somebody
drives those high performance
applications would be able to use those
models
by just installing them um
through their compiler you know so
that's um if you are interested in this
initiative
you can go to the link here you know
it's a
second state ai as a service native
model
that's
so here are some resources to get you
started there's a guide
there's tutorials and documentation
and there's again this is a link to the
fast
so that's it um thank you very much for
um
for attending my talk and i hope i i
i'll see you in the community as um um
you know reach out to me if you have
questions comments or want to criticize
our approach you know we welcome all
comments and just go to our website and
find our contact information
thank you very much i'll talk to you
later